google has released some data showing
that requests by governments all over
the world is beyond bonkers skyrocketing
so let's let's look at some of the
numbers so Google had eighteen hundred
and eleven requests in the first half to
remove information from various
governments and then 2285 in the second
half of 2012 and I thought this was
fascinating the top five countries that
are requesting Google remove information
Brazil number one us to Germany three
India four and Turkey five so let's
start with that country list before we
get into the hard core numbers about it
kind of faceting us number two shouldn't
go USA no but shouldn't Syria and Iran
where where are all the bad guys yeah
well maybe they're on that list you see
just because they don't put stuff up in
the first place so then they don't have
to it's less populated too so I'm sure
the numbers are staggering when you go
to Brazil in the United States so the
amount of requests right but but don't
we think we are Internet is totally free
here and right there's nothing that the
government could possibly not want on
the Internet yeah a particular law
that's you know you can't say something
before an election about a politician
which you would think that's when you
would want to say things about a
politician so their numbers are skewed
but the that's my problem with the u.s.
I mean we have the wiretapping on the
one hand and it's total invasion of our
privacy and then on the other hand if
you say something the government doesn't
like whoa well we're gonna have to take
that down and I mean we're supposed to
be the bastion of the First Amendment
freedom of speech etc and so it's really
disconcerting to see us at number two
and then as I was reading the article I
was the rest of the top five were in the
last paragraph I'm like show me Turkey
show me Turkey I know it's there boom
Turkey and you know why cuz I haven't
grown up Turkish everybody's offended
ever at everything like if you draw a
mustache on Ataturk the father of Turkey
like oh my god youtube take it down take
it down
someone is criticized doctor and hey
just get over it dude it's gonna be all
right right but yet the end part that
you're talking about I mean this rarely
gets overlooked you know when there's
the the film about Mohammed and then you
know Egypt wants YouTube to take stuff
down so that leads to my next
churches should Google Google's
basically bigger than all the world's
governments at this point part at this
point should they get involved in this
kind of stuff or just say tough we're
just putting it all out there and it's
it's tough because you know there's
freedom of speech and although you know
I'm all fairly yeah well and I'm all for
freedom of speech but then with this
whole Information Age now it's just
freedom to lie is what it's basically
become so where is that line where we
can't a we got to figure out how we can
prove that this freedom of speech we
have is the truth that's and that's why
everyone's so confused in this country
is because I'm watching the news for
five minutes as porn for work and I hear
on the news you know a cow was purple
today I'm gonna believe that even though
that cow was never purple but I'm gonna
go the rest of my life thinking that was
because I never heard the rebuttal of
that what's just Fox News according but
yes I mean it's just everyone just
throws anything out there and people are
gonna believe it because you're you're
being told yeah isn't that just the
price you have to pay for freedom I mean
the social media has given us this
incredible way of connecting people
basically started the Arab Spring in
Egypt but it's gonna come with a cost
for example right now in Egypt you could
argue that they're they're worse off
than they were under Mubarak freedom is
it free right and so it there is a cost
to it and you know the more the reason
I'm so worried about us being number two
on that list and of course they're among
the bigger population in the world and I
get that and China is in a whole
different category in how they shut down
Google etc and they've had huge problems
with Google and Google is in a tough
spot because they're like look I want to
be all over the world but if I you know
don't do what that government says all
of a sudden I don't have access to that
giant market so I kind of feel bad for
them in that sense but look look if your
government is trying to stop you from
learning something be worried right and
so for example the innocence of Muslims
like if you're a Muslim and you really
believe and you think Allah is up in
heaven etc why would Allah who knows
everything and is all-powerful be
offended by a YouTube video right so and
if they're trying to keep that from you
should make you go hmm
I I wonder if we're afraid of something
that people might find out something
they're not supposed to write well that
goes to that whole education thing that
Lance was talking about earlier about
why that's the most important because
really critical thinking is the most
important part but my final question on
this is how would we know at the end of
the day how would we know if our
government right now was censoring stuff
that they didn't want us to know I
looking at my Twitter timeline if you're
not if you don't see it you don't see it
so I guess we're just all wilful idiots
is that fair to say well you hope that
people raise a ruckus if something or
somebody disappears so and there's still
some good reporters out there Glenn
Greenwald David Sirota Jeremy Scahill
etc and so so there's some few people
still on the watch but yeah largely if
you know if you're not reading those
guys and something went away because the
government didn't want her to be there
yeah that's a tough situation so you can
read those guys or I recommend Lance
Bass jankura on twitter both you guys
have your real names by the way we all
know that's why they still mine back so
that's using it yeah and you probably
had them snuffed out on the DL they're
disappearing yeah exactly controlling
information I want to remind you guys
that the official outfitter of the Rubin
report is bonobos go to bonobos com use
code TRR to zero and get yourself this
fancy shirt